[Music]
here in this video we will discuss in
detail about the home world of the
predators their planetary system their
culture within it as well and some of
the history with them and other alien
species that has happened in it so let's
get to it the planet the enigmatic
predator homeworld of yautja prime has
seen minimal screen time in movies and
comic books now the information we do
have is a little bit contradictory
particularly in regards to the distance
from earth and a surface appearance in
the movie alien versus predator requiem
we see yautja prime being an earth-like
planet but not really similar to that of
our planet in many aspects as well
although it seems that there doesn't
appear to be much flora on the planet
since it is hot with flowing lava and
some cloud cover there are some
forest biomes as well it makes logical
that the planet has a hot climate
because the predators enjoy hunting when
it's hottest on earth and also given
that the planet contains at least two
suns so two sources of heat means a
hotter and a more arid climate
so let's take a look at their star
system the planet yautja prime orbit
around two suns and this type of star
system is called a binary one there
usually is a bigger star and a smaller
star but sometimes there are two of a
similar size anyway as we can see in the
movie requiem there is one star that is
a main sequence star resembling our sun
and another which seems to be a red
dwarf judging by the luminosity and the
size since the only other red stars
would be giants and supergiants and you
know those super giants aren't exactly
planet friendly so to say so the planet
the algebra prime could either orbit one
of these stars just as a moon does to a
planet and then these two would revolve
around the bigger entity or the planet
would have an orbit much further away
from both of them and it won't be a
normal spherical orbit due to the dual
centers of gravity okay back to the
planet let's see its atmosphere and its
geography the surface of the planet
appears to be riddled with canyons and
mountains pyramids resembling those of
the original alien vs predator movie
are among the large stone buildings in
the background there are at least two
major biomes on the planet a humid wet
rainforest biome and a dry hot desert
climate with rivers of boring lava the
majority of the world's land is probably
hot and humid avp requiem indicates that
there is still a lot of active volcanic
activity with little radioactive zones
in the volcanic regions as for the air
it would be similar to our own with a
variable percentage of oxygen and
nitrogen or another inert gas as a major
constituent and that we can infer by the
predator's ability to breathe our air
and function perfectly without a mass so
what about life on that planet let's see
its life forms and as we have seen there
is not much vegetation in the planet but
there could be pockets of jungle biomes
scattered around the the world planet
which would be necessary to regulate the
oxygen levels in the atmosphere in
predator homeworld comics we see a
barren rocky planet where predators live
in tribal communities anyway we do know
that there are at least eight species of
animals including the predators and the
others being the hellhounds the predator
dogs the predator horse blood pigs the
flying bird like keeps us the phoenix
like with the rack and the deadly quads
are rich that are a part of the blooding
ritual of the yavjas so these are the
life forms of the alga prime now let's
go to its ancient history let's start
with the rule of the mengi so apart from
the physical characteristics of the
planet we also have its diverse and rich
history which we have learned from the
movies comics and games so thousands of
years in the past when the predators
were a more primitive species the planet
was invaded and colonized by an alien
species called the amengi the amengi
enslaved the primitive locals known as
the hish which were neanderthal-like
versions of the predators unless evolved
form the hish were brutally governed by
the amengi who employed them as slaves
amusement and even food these aliens are
an insectoid race that to a human would
resemble man-sized crocodiles fitted
with various technological devices on
its body but due to their living in
luxury their ability for war faded away
and an uprising took place
now we come to the uprising of the hish
so these hish were ancient ancestors of
the species who were present several
millennia before on yautja prime the
hedge supposedly did not differ too far
in appearance from the modern day
yautjas or predators though they were
shorter and far more primitive and
intellectually underdeveloped but there
was one his name is kyle and he was an
especially huge and cunning hedge who
continues to be a legendary figure in
yautja lore he coordinated the cruel and
bloody slave insurrection that resulted
in the swift downfall and killing of the
amengi and the amenity were completely
defeated by kale and his rebels despite
having superior technology and those who
survived were made into slaves
themselves thus the turnings have tabled
the tables of turn the hish would go on
to seize the amengi's technology for
themselves adopting it into their own
culture and eventually creating an
unusual blend of both advanced science
and primeval savagery so for thousands
of years on the yautja would slowly
adapt and evolve aided by the technology
left behind by the mengi and they would
become the ruthless and deadly predators
that we have in present times they would
spread out to other worlds and encounter
as well as hunt down many alien species
including the xenomorphs river ghosts
and sometimes in space jockeys and us
humans which might be their most deadly
prey a topic which we will discuss in
another video anyway the predators would
for many millennia cultivate a strong
culture based on clans led by leaders
and matriarchs and sometimes on
occasions even having a supreme leader
or a king but all that will change in
the 21st century though civil war in the
movie predators of 2010 we get a glimpse
of the yao just current social and
political problems as well as in the
games and comics there are bad bloods
which are been rejected or exiled from
society which were heretics or a
different sub-species of individuals who
have disgraced the culture and branded
as heretics so the berserkers the super
predators of the movie were examples of
them and it seems that they as the
bigger ones
were even hunting the hunters of species
the smaller ones as was stated in the
movie the blood feud would have become a
long civil war and with the predator
species seen in predator comics set in
the future it seems that the smaller
ones the ones with clans and all would
have come out as victorious but that is
all we have to say about what has
happened in the yautja prime homeworld
of the predators so yeah take it fam